TODD SHAIMAN: Hello, everyone.
Thanks for your patience.
First of all, I'm Todd Shaiman.
I am the Head of Content
Strategy for Google VR.
It's so amazing to see
so many people here,
and I'm so excited
for all the interest,
and I choose to believe
that this is just
a sign of great,
great things to come.
I am going to
talk-- I was trying
to think about what would be
an interesting topic as it
pertains to Jump.
First of all, who
knows what Jump is?
OK.
Cool.
Well, I'll start to
explain it for those
whose hands didn't go up.
But I-- oh, whoa.
Why is this taking
off without me?
AUDIENCE: It's jumping.
TODD SHAIMAN: It's jumping.
All right.
I guess I'm-- All right.
There we go.
All right.
So what I thought I would
do is talk about a project
that one of my colleagues,
Jessica Brillhart,
did that was to create some
original content when we
announced Jump back in
May at Google I/O. Jessica
is a terrific filmmaker, and
when we originally put Jump
together, she took the
camera around the world
and filmed something that
we could demonstrate at I/O.
So a lot-- these insights
that I'm gonna talk about are
Jessica's-- I'm
merely the messenger.
But I think they're
really interesting,
and I think that
hopefully they'll
create some good fodder
for conversation.
So what is Jump?
We announced it
at I/O this year,
and it's basically three things.
It's a 360 stereo
capture rig that
has 16 cameras in a circle.
We're working on
that with GoPro.
And the second thing
is the assembler.
And this is part of the
magic of this pipeline.
It basically takes
computer vision,
lots of Google computers, and
stitches the footage seamlessly
together in an
insanely fast way.
And it takes a
significant pain point out
of the process of
having to manually
massage all of these different
cameras into a seamless image.
And then the third thing,
which we've heard a bunch
about already, is YouTube.
And basically, we
want anyone, anywhere,
to be able to experience all
of these amazing stereo 360
experiences.
And there's no better platform
than that in the world,
we believe, than YouTube.
So when we step back--
and when Jessica went out
to make this first
piece of content
using the prototype Jump rig--
the state of editorial in VR,
she describes as
something like this.
It's really all over the place.
And this talk is really
designed to kind of highlight
some of the things that we've
learned through this experience
and some other ones.
And the first thing that we
did is came up with a name.
Probabilistic
Experiential Editing.
We know that the
acronym needs some work.
[LAUGHTER]
But we think that
it actually touches
on a lot of how you might
think about editing in 360.
So let's break it down.
First, probabilistic.
How likely a viewer is to see
something, and to do something.
So this is basically, like, how
likely is a person experiencing
this particular scene likely
to look in a particular way,
or act a particular way?
And the reality is you
don't totally know.
But what you do know is there
are various points of interest
around, and you can use
that as a way to bet
on where someone is looking.
You don't know for
sure, but you can guess.
So here's an example.
This is a bunch of rocks.
When Jessica went
around the world,
she went to amazing places.
This was not a bad gig--
to Iceland, Japan, Puerto
Rico-- a lot of places
to film with the rig.
So this was one of those places.
Is there anywhere that you
might probabilistically bet
that someone might be looking?
Not necessarily.
There are a few of these
things-- little peaks--
but you don't really know.
However, here--
this scene has what
you could consider a definitive
point of interest, right?
The climber.
And in addition to the
visual point of interest,
the sound emanating
from the environment
is coming from him
too, which you probably
won't be able to
hear, but trust me.
So you can't be assured that
someone's going to look there,
but you can have a
reasonable guess.
So here's another
one, where here, there
are four points of interest
that are all the windows.
And you'd expect someone to
be looking through windows
like you would in real life.
And then from an
audio perspective,
the announcer is
speaking, so you
can see her speaking
in this scene,
and hear the output
from that speaker.
that's circled up there.
So back to the mountain climber.
It's very likely that someone's
looking at this climber,
although you can't count on it.
But you can use that
to your advantage,
and you can cut from
him to something else
that you want the
viewer to witness.
And so this can be
called-- it's a match cut,
but instead of a visual match,
it's an attention match.
That's the way you
might think about it.
So you can cut
from here to here.
OK.
And there are a lot of
examples in this, right?
All right.
Next word.
Experiential.
So this is the notion of the
interaction between the viewer
and the scene.
And really what
this means is there
are contexts for
different environments
that you can kind of anticipate
how someone might experience it
just like they
would in the world.
So it's determined by the
viewer and by our experiences.
So how long do
you expect someone
to want to stay in
a certain place?
Or how long will certain things
hold someone's attention,
and why?
And these are, again,
not determinant,
but there are things
you can play with.
So here, back to the tram.
So you know where someone
most likely look, but why?
And how?
And probably they're
going to be doing
the same thing that
they'd be doing while
in a tram in real life.
Not looking at a
window, but looking out
of a window, which
means you can motivate
a cut by reciprocating, or
extending, that experience.
So here's an example of that.
So if you're looking
through that window,
you are rewarded
by, well, I guess,
either that window
or these windows--
so if you're looking
through the deep window,
you're rewarded by
the corridor there.
And if you're looking
out the other windows,
you're rewarded by a
horse looking back at you.
So, again, none of this
is 100% determined,
but you can really use
this, and play with it,
and really be kind of
experimental and playful
with it.
All right.
Bear with me as I'm flipping
between these computers.
So sometimes the
kind of environment
can inform the interaction
just as much as
what the viewer brings to it.
So here's an example of that.
This is back to the rocks.
So these rocks are
actually pretty important.
And when Jessica
initially cut this,
she used the rocks as an on
ramp for a new experience.
It's relatively
calm, and the viewer
can get a sense of the
rules of the experience
without being thrust
into things too quickly,
before moving into
the next shot.
And so once you establish
that comfort level,
you can play with
it, and then you
can jump into a new shot
that has more to it.
And, in this case,
what the next shot had
was an audio base that
was on a different side,
and caused the viewer
to turn and take
advantage of the 360ness
of this whole thing.
All right.
Editing.
So how is traditional
editing done?
Clip to clip, kind of
in a linear way, right?
There's one scene, and another
scene, and another scene.
And so how do you think
about it in 360 space?
Well, one way just visually
to think about it is not that,
but from the center and out.
And so what does that mean, and
what are implications of that?
I mean, one general
implication--
which a lot of
people talk about,
but it's true-- is you
think more about crafting VR
like a game than a film.
It's more like MYST than it
would be like "The Godfather."
And there a lot of other
things there, too, but I'm
going to skip ahead to this.
So this is sort of the notion
of playfulness with this stuff.
And this is all-- and I'd love
to hear if others have thoughts
and experiences around
what has worked what
hasn't-- but the notion of
rebelliousness and playfulness
around what the expectation
is in cutting to something,
or cutting around
to something else,
and when those
transitions should happen.
And have fun with it.
So here's an example of that.
So this was a ferry ride
that was in the world tour.
And if you're looking where
the kind of expected place
was to look, you're looking
out forward on the ferry.
But then if you turn
around, you actually
see Jessica, the filmmaker,
in the background.
And she put herself
in there intentionally
in sort of a reward to
look around like that.
And there's a lot
of ways you can
surprise your viewers that way.
Here's another one
where-- as opposed
to a smooth transition,
when the ferry ride ends,
you jump an entirely new, quiet
scenario where a guy's working
on a motorcycle.
And play with your
audience that way,
and see what the
impact of that is.
So it's all about discovery.
You can plant things in
a scene in such a way
that the viewer discovers them,
and discovers new elements.
And you keep them surprised
and inline, but also guessing.
So and if you get--
I think it is,
it's kind of like a dance--
dance with the viewer.
And if you think about
the discovery environment,
you really start to
make some amazing stuff.
And this obviously varies
by the type of content
that you're creating.
In this case, this is disparate
pieces, and how you weave them
together, but I think it has
implications more broadly,
and it's pretty interesting.
All right.
So this is the creed--
the working creed.
So that's the challenge
and the excitement of this,
and how it might be different
than what we see elsewhere.
So in the near
future, the squiggle
becomes something more uniform.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]